okay so here we are eating your feed
[Music]
i'm riye my friend nikki challenged me
to make this cube cheese bread i usually
don't
be challenged but nikki's special friend
so i accepted her challenge cheesy bread
it's sold
in milk cow in boots in seoul korea
this video shot by hungry empire take
out bread
and break in half and there is
cheesy sauce oozing out and it's very
steamy
it looks good the bread shape is like
cube it's not
too foreign to me because all of
japanese bread is sold in
kind of cube i was thinking it might be
like
bechamel bechamel is one of the mada
sauce
it's basically like a creamy white sauce
this time i want to make it cheesy so
i'm going to maybe add some like
white cheese i'm going to make probably
three batch of
dough i can kind of test several
different ways
i want to make bechamel cheese situation
and maybe like block of cheese and
maybe like soft tooth situation and
see which one has the most cheesy
outcome usually
i'm the one who helps whenever something
goes wrong
but today i have
mostly just because i like the three of
us together how is this physically
possible though there's no bread in
there
that's true oh that kind of makes me a
little bit worried about it it's like
all cheese
someone commented only wizards can make
that kind of bread are you a wizard
today
if i make it i'd be a certified wizard
oh
right thank you okay so let's get
ingredient
[Music]
got some cheese eat debris will be just
folding into the dough
i got grill white cheddar this is for
bechamel
first i'm going to make bechamel can you
grate cheese for me
i think so it's going to be easy just
don't grate your finger
tattoo i've never grated cheese before
you've never grated cheese before i
don't eat cheese oh that's true yeah
lactose it's easy this is now a try
video
okay feels okay
oh she's got it feel the pressure
first melt four tablespoons of butter
and quarter cup of flour
so you want to cook at least two minutes
so eliminates
kind of flour flavor one and a half cup
milk
little by little i thought it'd be more
satisfying than this
it feels like nothing is happening i
think if you grate everything
and if you open it it will be very
satisfying
we're gonna add salt
we'll stay cheese tower
we think we'll get mad if i only use the
hot
wait i'm gonna add this
sharp cheddar guyel that honey freshly
grated
wow it's very cheesy do you want to try
okay
[Music]
it's cheesy but it's very cheesy i want
more okay
yeah your hard work paid off oh yeah
i'm gonna use all of it so i think
i'm gonna freeze it so i can easily fold
into the dough
so you're making like cheese ice cubes
yeah
to put into a bread cube so i'm gonna
set aside and
make bread okay so i'm going to make
bread
i'm using the recipe i did a video when
i was in japan called
um shakbang which is the same bread
japanese daily bread
you can find anywhere what makes it
different from
regular bread the difference between
japanese
chocolate and american bread is the
shape
texture is a little bit different a
little bit fluffier
and a little bit sweeter so i have 1000
grams of flour
i'm gonna do the same here four
tablespoon
sugar two teaspoon of salt i'm going to
lightly mix the dry ingredients two cups
of warm water
one cup of warm milk three teaspoon
of yeast and mix for
like seven to eight minutes four
tablespoon butter
each butter is a little cold so i'm like
warming up in a hot
okay i think it's good yeah
it looks good
thank you my hand
it's like butter
hold it really there you go
so i'm gonna just shape into round
oh how heavy is it i feel like it's
uh two kittens please make a cookbook
where all of the measurements are
in cats it's my dream
would you buy it yeah 100
nice two babies two
doll beads and we are going to
do the first proof which is one hour and
it should
double the volume and we are going to
put in a nice and
warm place they want to be comfortable
me too here we are
eating your feet it's doubled it's huge
yeah okay so now i'm going to
punch it and relieve the gas
why it's so funny you punch me you could
also release some gas
yes
oh
wow okay punch it
oh my god so soft
i'm dividing dough into six
it looks like the size is inconsistent
but it's on purpose
because i'm not sure how much space i'm
going to need
how does it feel annie i can't do this
i feel like my arm mine's so lumpy
it's okay so i'm going to cover this
with stump
towel for 20 minutes so cute
snap time
so this is my frozen bechamel
it's not perfect shape but i think we
can go from there
i have two molds so
i'm going to fill one with
bechamel cheese cube and
the other one is brie we need a lot of
filling in order to achieve that like
lava
effect so i think this is yeah
i don't know i've never done that so
dough has been rested for 20 minutes
and i'm going to stuff this
so i'm gonna put frozen bechamel
my fear is if i stuff too much filling
it's going to explode inside of the
bread
so i have to make sure i close the bread
when i
fold it in like a gift surprise gift box
so i'm going to put this in a mold
okay this one is pretty
close the steam really well
hope it works okay so i'm going to close
the lid
and i'm going to put on top of the oven
because it's warm
and nice and do second proof
the one with brie is proofed nicely
so we are going to bake 350 for 20
minutes
how will you know if it's melted and
inside no we don't know
we will know when you break it
[Music]
wow this one's debris right
this is brie it's still
super hot so i want to cool it down a
little bit
[Music]
so i cooled about five minutes and
now i can touch it so i'm ready to break
it
thumbs in thumbs in thumbs in pull it
apart
[Music]
it's good isn't it it's pretty good
look at this yeah melty cheese how's the
steam
yeah yeah that's steaming cheers
oh yeah oh that's delicious do you want
to eat it
yeah yeah yeah get in here yeah that's
really good yeah right yes
am i uh certified wizard yes you are
certified wizard please put a wizard's
hat on here and maybe some stars and it
may be like a
beard you won eating your feed
yeah that's how this works you win thank
you i won this has been season three of
eating your feed
[Applause]
so awkward
you did put the bechamel one in the oven
already that's true so we got to take it
out anyways yeah
it looks different
no i feel like it's good yeah why
they look like it looks a little
separated oh yeah
and no meltiness let's
taste it great really
you